hey guys welcome to a new episode of the
Wednesday checkup today I'm gonna be
sharing the story with you it happened a
couple of weeks ago where unfortunately
a patient filed a complaint against me
that made me really emotional let me
tell you why before we start I want to
let you know I'm gonna be changing some
details about the patient just so we
maintain this person's privacy and we
don't make anybody feel uncomfortable
because that is not the goal of this
channel our job is to stay happy healthy
learn about ourselves learn from our
mistakes and that's what we're gonna do
with today's story here we go let's get
started to set the scene I'm working in
my outpatient Family Medicine office and
I see a patient on my schedule I have
the demographics that he's a male he's
in his late 20s and also the complaint
or reason why he made the appointment
patient would like MRI for low back pain
patient comes in my nurse rooms the
patient I go in and we start having a
conversation the history of present
illness goes as follows the patient is
late 20s male works many hours in his
job as a department store salesman where
he's on his feet he's been complaining
of low back pain for an extended period
of time
were sometimes getting better sometimes
currently is not in a lot of pain
somewhere like three to five out of ten
it does get pretty bad at times going
all the way up to an eight this patient
has had prior back surgery we don't
really have a clear understanding as to
what the surgery was and what the
indication for the surgery was but we
know there was a back surgery performed
and my first question is because my goal
is to help the patient and answer the
patient's question directly was you told
me or at least you told my nurse that
you would like an MRI what are you
looking to find out what the MRI he
wants an MRI because he's worried that
the activities he's doing in his
everyday life could be causing more
damage to his low back and that perhaps
there may be scar tissue from the past
surgery or perhaps there's something
else going on within his lumbar or
thoracic spine that could be causing his
symptoms I understood where he was
coming from so I said okay let's take
that apart piece by piece and we'll have
a longer conversation than we originally
scheduled the visit
was supposed to be 15 minutes which is
normally what we get for an acute visit
but I said well we'll spend extra time
because I really want us to both be on
the same page and especially because
I've never seen you before I want to
create a little bit of a relationship
before giving any kind of advice or
guidance one of my first questions being
sports medicine an osteopathic medicine
trained was do you do any kind of
physical activities and how does your
back pain affect that he told me that
every morning or pretty much five days
out of the week he does calisthenics in
the morning for about half an hour and
he's able to do those pain free and
actually he gets a lot of benefit from
doing this calisthenics and stretching
also at least once a week he goes on
like an eight nine mile hike after the
eighth or ninth mile he starts
developing low back pain that makes it
uncomfortable for him to continue and he
has to cut his hike short what do I take
as a doctor from that kind of
information well first it shows me that
this patient is very functional that
they're able to do stretches they're
able to do complicated and compound
movements they're not limited incredibly
by this back pain that was a good sign
for me because as a doctor my job is
always to get my patients moving
especially when it comes to low back
pain there was a misconception back in
the day that if your low back hurts you
should rest it that's actually pretty
inaccurate because what we found is the
longer time you spend in bed with low
back pain the worse that can actually
get now this was my first time seeing
the patient so I asked what's going on
in my patients life he described a very
stressful life especially when it comes
to work he's working many hours 12 to 14
hours at times and the back pain gets
worse after standing all day and at
times the patient even became tearful
because he was so upset about the
stressors in his life with family
friends there was a lot of things going
on but I could see that stress was a
major component and there was a big
mental component of this pain so after
getting the full history and what was
going on with his back pain I perform a
physical exam now the physical exam the
patient had some muscle spasms straight
leg raise which is the test that we do
to check for sciatica was actually
negative which is a good sign that means
that the sciatic nerve is not involved
in this type of pain I did some other
provocative tests and everything came up
negative there were some tender points
that I elicited but nothing that was
really worrisome no bony tender
the reflexes were fine those are
important things that we rule out when
we're looking at someone's back pain so
once I conducted the proper history that
I did the full physical I then decided
to explain to the patient what my
thoughts are on whether or not he needs
an MRI I told the patient that an MRI
wouldn't benefit him because what we
find on MRIs doesn't always translate to
clinical symptoms in fact it doesn't the
majority of the time there have been
studies done in the past where we
scanned a hundred people who have no
back pain and found that on MRIs they
had significant findings arthritic
changes a degenerative changes bulging
discs but these patients weren't having
back pain so what does that tell us that
tells us that just because you have a
finding on that on the MRI it doesn't
mean that it'll have a clinical
significance and as a doctor it's not my
job to treat the MRI it's to treat my
patient so I told the patient that based
on how functional they are based on my
physical exam knowing that they're able
to do calisthenics everyday hike freight
miles
I can barely hike for eight miles their
back pain seemed more tied to their
stress levels in their job now
that's not to say my patient doesn't
have a true medical problem they do and
it's elicited by tender points they're
describing pain which is a subjective
measure but they are describing it and
they're saying how uncomfortable they
are so it's my job to fix that so what I
explained to the patient is I thought
that they could benefit from
conservative management specifically
physical therapy I also recommended some
osteopathic manipulation and I gave a
recommendation of some reading material
about mind body conditions where based
on our mental state some physical
problems can arise like low back pain as
a primary care doctor it's my job to
delay the process of risky procedures as
much as I can as long as there's no
pressing matters at hand
I didn't view that an MRI was the
correct next step but I understand that
some patients may have reservations
about that I understand that they can
have anxieties about their back pain for
example why is it there I would like to
get a better look so I explain that to
the patient if you don't agree with my
evaluation or you think that you still
need an MRI after this discussion I'll
happily write you a prescription for an
MRI and we can get the process started
or I'd like to see you back the
following week so we can continue this
conversation you would have started
physical therapy by now and got in a
couple of sessions in and we could see
what progress you're making and if an
during that point you decide that you
want to write I'll write you the MRI
then I'll write you a referral to a
specialist if that's what you want and
my patient seemed to be very
understanding doctor I appreciate you
spending the time I see what you're
saying I don't want them are I now I
hear you I'll see you next week I'll
start physical therapy and we'll go from
there and I was really proud of myself
as a doctor it's not always easy to have
a patient walk in who wants something
and it's your job to convince them for
their own good or at least from your
medical opinion for their own good that
it's not ideal what they want and that
there's a better way and for them to
understand that and be on the same page
that takes skill and sometimes it takes
many years for doctors to develop that
skill I came back the following week to
my hospital a patient called and left a
complaint with our office manager the
complaint was basically as follows that
the doctor that I saw did not help me at
all with my pain this doctor was overly
spiritual and I'd like to see a real
doctor who's willing to help me with my
pain it was something along those lines
I'm paraphrasing the rest of the day I
was left feeling like what kind of I had
done better what what did I do wrong
where did the communication break down
so I started replaying the situation
over and over in my head trying to
figure out what I can do better how I
can improve and something that I do is I
ask people who have more experience than
myself or people who are experts in
other fields for their advice so I want
to go see one of our behavioral
specialists that work in within our
office and basically what he told me is
there are some patients which is a small
percentage of patients like less than
10% even less than 5% probably the more
care you give them the more time you
spend with them the more effort you try
and go through in explaining something
the more they take away from that
something negative why is this doctor
trying to sell me on this what is this
dog is he trying to get over me on this
especially if you're disagreeing what
they initially came in for and he said
what's a good strategy for that
basically going into the patient's room
now that you know that their personality
style and type
and just being very buttoned up well you
want an MRI I don't think it's in your
best interest to get an MRI and say that
you know if you don't disagree with this
here's I can give you a referral to see
a specialist another doctor or the test
that you actually want ordered what it
taught me was that at certain times with
certain personalities it makes sense to
be more brief and to be more succinct
than just explain things clearly instead
of trying to sell and influence that
person because they can come off
manipulative to some people you can't
fault yourself for everything the
situation could just happen because of
an unfortunate coincidence if you will
the fact that this patient never met me
I never met the patient I tried to be
really nice the patient misinterpreted
that for whatever reason the patient
filed a complaint but the people that
know me and the nurses and other
patients will understand that my
intentions were good intentions matter
there's many times where we have great
intentions but have bad outcomes
we need to always look at the intentions
and then look at the outcomes if the
intentions were bad now we know that
person needs some work on that end of
the spectrum if the intentions were good
but the outcomes were bad then we need
to work on the action and figure out
what we need to improve on that action I
want to keep learning as a doctor and I
feel like if we can learn together along
on this unique journey of mine I think
that's even more special and that's why
YouTube was created speaking of good
intentions and bad outcomes check out my
mental health video right here stay
happy and healthy and I'll see you in
this video